yo what is up everybody it is prestige
from mad luigi here with some more
borderlands sippy sequel video content
today we're going to be talking about
the new and fi final major dlc
announced by uh gearbox and
2k australia which is the claptastic
voyage plus some other stuff like the
level a level cap
increase and i actually think that's the
main two things
so i think pax east is the one is the
packs that just happened and
at pax east gearbox announced the
new uh and final of the main four dlcs
for borderlands super sequel
if you have a season pass this will be
your final of the four dlcs promised on
the season pass
and this is going to be the last major
installment of downloadable content
for this game called borderlands every
sequel
there's a quick one one half minute uh
trailer that is out
that gives you a little bit of the
insights to what this new dlc is going
to be
and it is where most of the information
is coming up from
uh to this other than the actual
announcement so this
is going to be available on march 24th
so the end of this month
and it's going to be a full big story of
story dlc now it has been said that this
is going to be larger than tiny t
uh the tiny tina dlc like tiny tina's
assault on dragon keep for borderlands 2
and that was a really big dlc and
like that was a very very well received
dlc
so if this is up to those standards it's
going to be a really great dlc
now in this dlc jack has found handsome
jack has found something super
incredibly powerful
and as such it has to be his so he
he is sending his vault hunters into the
mind of a claptrap
and this is the super powerful whatever
it is is inside claptrap so you have to
go into claptrap
and fight through all of his memories
and his brain
and find out what the super powerful
thing is and get it back for jack
now it has in the trailer you see a lot
of new enemies
um um new weapons they those are the two
key points that they talked about in the
trailer we'll not even talk about like
show very small things
so there's a lot of robot enemies it
looks like some really different enemies
so it looks like we're gonna get
actual new not re-skinned enemies but
like
new robot enemies that act in different
ways uh just like
the um big berserker thing that you
found that we found in the
holodome like that was a completely new
enemy i think we're gonna have more like
that
there's also kind of big they kind of
look like really big robot dogs that are
me riding around
and there's one robot that looked like
rob a rob
or rb one of those um the nintendo
character
uh one of the robots look like that and
i've also heard
tell of some the weapon system is going
to be there's
going to be a new style of weapon um
that is a malfunctioning weapon system
which i know doesn't sound
super great but i think it's gonna be i
i saw i forget the article but
one article i was reading i saw that it
said um
like imagine an smg shooting so you're
shooting your smg
and suddenly it shoots one of the
bullets like a shotgun
so you have that type of weapon stuff
happening which i think will be a really
cool thing
if they choose to go with that
regardless we're gonna have some new
weapons we're gonna have some new
enemies and hopefully it's gonna be a
really big
story uh and really great story dlc
i will be posting videos um i'm
thinking about posting a full
playthrough of it i haven't really done
a playthrough of anything but
i'll be i might do a full playthrough uh
video set of it also
i will be doing if there are any
legendaries
or like super good uniques are there any
legendaries or good uniques that i
really want to do a video
on i'll do a video on of how to get them
and kind of just
analysis what they're like so i think
that's going to be it for the video
um you guys that have gotten this far i
have this far in the video
i'm assuming you guys are some of my
subscribers uh i think this is is this
the enemy that i was talking about
uh yeah yeah that that thing that's a
new enemy like but like
so new enemies like that but as i was
saying
i i know for all the people that got
this from the video i'm assuming
you're uh pretty invested in my channel
and uh just uh
to say so i do want to say that i
apologize
for my lack of videos in the recent like
months i know in the past two months
i've put up like
i put up a very small amount of videos
and i it's been part
i didn't know i didn't have anything to
put up and part i've been really busy
so i do apologize for that and i will do
my best to work farther
um in the future for that however until
this new dlc
comes out i probably won't be putting up
too many videos however
hopefully when this dlc comes out i'll
be doing a lot of videos on it
so guys hope you've enjoyed the video
and if you like this
check out my channel for a bunch more
borland's for sequel content
and that's about it i'll see you guys on
i guess march 24th yeah
it's probably gonna be a tuesday i
haven't looked but
games like releasing things on tuesdays
so i'll see you guys later peace out